aujourd'hui nos concitoyens qui se
voient prescrire du paracétamol ou de
l'amoxicilline se voit délivré du
paracétamol ou de l'amoxicilline qu'ils
en soi rassurés pour autant existe-t-il
des tensions sur le marché la réponse
est oui des problèmes
d'approvisionnement touchent depuis
plusieurs semaines certains médicaments
le gouvernement se veut rassurant qu'en
est-il des médecins comment nettoyer là
y a-t-il de graves conséquences c'est ce
que nous allons voir dans factures
tout d'abord quel médicament sont
concernés parmi eux on retrouve le
paracétamol plus connu sous le nom de
doliprane lorsqu'il est commercialisé
par le laboratoire Sanofi il y a aussi
l'amoxicilline qui traite principalement
les angines et les otites des enfants
c'est l'antibiotique le plus prescrit en
France c'est véritablement la première
année que nous avons cette problématique
les problématiques des ruptures de
médicaments pour d'autres raisons
étaient existées mais pas sur ces
médicaments pédiatriques pour de grandes
consommations qui sont donc le
paracétamol l'amoxicilline et la
prédisiologue il y en a plus que l'année
précédente on estime que cette année en
2022 il y en a eu près 3000 depuis le
début d'année
ce qui est largement super aux années
précédentes donc oui il y a une
augmentation depuis évidemment une
dizaine d'années ça n'arrête pas
d'augmenter mais c'est particulièrement
important depuis depuis quelle est
l'origine de ces problèmes
d'approvisionnement le gouvernement
évoque plusieurs raisons tout d'abord le
covid-19 il aurait entraîné une hausse
de prescription de 13% pour le
paracétamol autre explication le
gouvernement pointe des soucis sur le
principe actif après les années 1990 la
plupart des laboratoires pharmaceutiques
ont délocalisé la production de
principes actifs vers des pays à bas
coût et c'est l'Inde et la Chine qui ont
raflé la mise avec plus des deux tiers
de la production mondiale ainsi les
laboratoires souhaitaient faire des
économies et se concentrer sur la
recherche de médicaments innovants
depuis trois quatre ans un retour en
Europe de la production de principes
actifs a été amorcé par des labor
pouvoir européen et américains et en
pleine pandémie l'État a encouragé cet
élan en finançant plusieurs dizaines de
projets de relocalisation problème il
faut attendre qu'il se concrétise il y a
une problématique sur la production du
principe actif évidemment si quand on a
des usines sur le soin de national on
peut leur demander de s'adapter de
d'augmenter les le rythme la cadence de
de faire en sorte de réserver la
production au marché national pour les
besoins de la population et donc on a
plus de moyens d'action l'Agence
nationale de sécurité du médicament et
des produits de santé soulignés aussi un
gain des besoins lié aux épidémies
hivernales la demande en amoxicilline
par exemple avec été plus faible durant
les années de pandémie de covid-19 grâce
à une moindre circulation des autres
maladies or cet automne la demande
mondiale augmente fortement en cause la
reprise épidémie avec la bronchiolite la
grippe et le covid à cela s'ajoutent les
répercussions de la guerre en Ukraine et
des reconfinements en Chine flambées des
prix de l'énergie et des matières
premières et des lait
d'approvisionnement rallongés mais
l'état n'a-t-il pas aussi sa part de
responsabilité oui bien sûr que l'État a
une part de responsabilité parce que
justement son rôle est de coordonner un
peu toutes les actions autour de
médicaments et on considère qu'il y a un
certain nombre d'actions qui devrait
être prises depuis plusieurs années déjà
et qui ne sont pas passés l'état ça part
de responsabilité parce que l'état d'une
part avec de très beaux discours et une
très belle volonté veut relocaliser la
production en France mais à chaque
projet de loi de finance sécurité
sociale il en [ __ ] le budget du
médicament de 800 millions un milliards
d'euros et ça depuis 2007 donc au fur et
à mesure de ces projets de loi massifs
de baisse de prix on arrive à des
médicaments qui ne valent quasiment plus
rien
et donc qui sont difficiles à avoir à
mettre sur le marché dans notre pays le
plan 2019-2022 de gestion des pénuries
de médicaments avaient été élaborés par
Agnès Buzyn la ministre de l'époque mais
il a été enterré avec la pandémie c'est
seulement ce 14 décembre que le
ministère indiqué qu'il prévoyait de
travailler sur ce plan dans les
prochains mois et si en 2021 Emmanuel
Macron avait annoncé un plan de
souveraineté sanitaire comprenant la
relocalisation en France du principe
actif du paracétamol les fabricants de
génériques ne sont pas convaincus ils
estiment que les prix de leurs produits
sont trop bas et ainsi ne permettent pas
le maintien de leur activité sur le
territoire cette problématique ne date
donc pas d'hier alors quand peut-on
imaginer un retour à la normale pour
Pallice et tensions les autorités
sanitaires demandent aux professionnels
de santé de veiller aux bons usages des
médicaments touchés elle recommande
notamment aux pharmacies une délivrance
à et les médecins sont priés de
respecter les bons usages sur les
antibiotiques parmi d'autres
propositions l'Agence nationale de
sécurité du médicament et des produits
de santé encouragés également la
recherche d'importation
d'importer des produits mais je pense
malheureusement que ça ne réglera pas le
problème parce que probablement tous les
pays européens sont dans la même
situation
donc ça va être compliqué c'est sûr
ces mesures devraient quand même
détendre la situation dans les
prochaines semaines voire moi selon le
gouvernement c'est un retour à la
normale dans les semaines et moi qui
viennent mais vous savez les chaînes de
production tournent à plein régime ça va
durer l'hiver évidemment la baisse de la
demande c'est à dire la baisse de la
consommation de ces molécules va nous
permettre de revenir à un niveau normal
mais d'autres sont plus inquiets je
pense que ça va durer des années parce
que pour régler les problèmes de fond
qui remontent à plusieurs années déjà
ça va pas se faire en cinq minutes si
vous prenez par exemple l'exemple de la
localisation dont on parle beaucoup
c'est un processus qui est long et
complexe cette pénurie pourrait être
encore durée alors a-t-elle des
conséquences graves il y a-t-il de quoi
s'inquiéter les hôpitaux sont
prioritaires sur le sur l'antibio sur la
délivrance des antibiotiques donc ça a
bien sûr pour la ville pour les
pharmacies c'est extrêmement gênant mais
les hôpitaux seront toujours
prioritaires et disposeront toujours
d'antibiotiques en quantité suffisante
pour soigner les pathologies lourdes ce
qui est sûr c'est qu'aujourd'hui
ça devient très compliqué pour les
soignants
pour par exemple les anticancéreux parce
que quand vous démarrez une campagne
avec un anti-cancéreux vous pouvez
difficilement changer au milieu donc
c'est clair que il y a des risques pour
la santé par ailleurs les principales
organisations de pédiatres et
infectiologues craignent que le manque
d'amoxicilline des bouches sur une crise
majeure de santé publique selon eux le
manque d'antibiotiques pourrait avoir
des conséquences meurtrières chez les
enfants elle recommande alors une
restriction drastique de la prescription
de cet antibiotique quitte à imposer des
contraintes aux médecins et appelle à ce
qu'un diagnostic précis soit donné sur
les ordonnances